scp 682 vs scp-407  could the song of genesis alter the hard  to destroy reptile out of existence  finally making it true music to the scp  foundation's ears at 25 seconds 682 did  not seem at all soothed by the music at  45 seconds the creature's wounds from a  previous test healed rapidly and it made  a high-pitched noise at one minute 25  seconds 682 screamed and its mouth began  to fill with a white foamy substance at  one minute 55 seconds it swallowed this  same substance and started choking  however at 2 minutes 35 seconds it  squirted all the substance out of its  mouth in a powerful jet and at 3 minutes  55 seconds 682 remained unconscious for  five minutes to heal and then awoke  utterly unaffected by the song of  genesis